so this disaster and it was a disaster
not just politically but internationally
we changed our Russia policy as a result
of this hoax
when on as long as it did because pretty
much nobody in Washington tried to put
the brakes on don't want to point
fingers or anything but for all of 2017
and 2018 Republicans control both houses
of Congress trey Gowdy was there serving
in the House Hotel committee he joins us
a congressman thanks so much for coming
on tonight sue yes sir I I think that
this was and I just said it from the
very beginning driven by the Obama
administration but it was allowed to
metastasize because the
republican-controlled Congress did not
stop it
why do you think that is well two things
let me just say you referenced Susan
Rice you need to read the rest of that
email Tucker and you can't because it
hasn't been Declassified but if you want
to fully understand what President Obama
knew and what role he played you need to
read and access the rest of Susan Rice's
email and hopefully it'll be
declassified one day and you can for
Russia
I thought Devon unas did a phenomenal
job this is what he said we're gonna
find out what Russia did with whom if
any one they did it how to make sure
they don't do it again in 2020 and then
the issue of unmasking x' and leaks so
there were four pores on what he wanted
us to look at
it's just nobody gave a damn about three
of them the only thing they cared about
was the with whom if anyone so we did
what 6070 witness interviews the Senate
did that much or more than we had Bob
Muller so look and my defensive of Devon
I am because he had an incredibly
difficult 2017 he wrapped up his
investigation a lot quicker than Bob
Muller did and with a lot less help from
the witnesses no I think I think that's
right I think the scariest part of all
of this is the behavior of the FBI the
most powerful law-enforcement agency in
the world
it's sinister what they did to Michael
Flint you were briefed by the FBI in
2018 and shortly after briefing came on
this channel to describe
your reaction to it here's what you said
then but as of now I think Chris Rea and
rod Rosenstein are stunned whenever
people think Trump is the target of
their investigation I'll leave it up to
them how to brief the President on how
to breathe through all that you're
talking about right now was that
strengthened when you went into this
briefing last week yes I am I am even
more convinced that the FBI did exactly
what my fellow citizens would want them
to do when they got the information they
got and that it has nothing to do with
Donald Trump
I remember watching that and thinking
boy I hope he's right
I do you still feel that way oh gosh no
no that was my made a lot of mistakes in
life relying on briefings and not
insisting on the documents it took me
about three weeks I went over the
Department of Justice I sat there for
four hours that's when I saw that Peters
truck actually initiated and approved
crossfire hurricane that's when I saw
the exploratory information on George
papadopolis that's when I saw for the
very first time that it was the Trump
campaign mentioned in that predicate
document they've been telling us all
along Trump's not the target
the campaign's not the target so yes my
mistake was relying on the word of the
FBI and the DOJ and not insisting all
the documents ray luckily it took me
about three weeks to correct that
mistake so that was in March in July
which is of course many months later you
said of the investigation it is not a
witch-hunt
you said point-blank it's not a witch
hunt and people say this is not but of
course it was a witch hunt by definition
when did that don't on you
well Tucker if you think about the four
points number one what did Russia do I
am convinced that Russia tried to
interfere with the fundamentals of our
democracy so point number one that that
we were asked to look at what did Russia
do number two with whom if anyone I was
down there for almost every witness
interview and I'm the one that asked the
question and the answer was no one what
the Trump campaign did anything with
Russia then we got to the unmasking zin
the leak so I don't think asking what
did Russia do to our country in 2016 or
tried to do I don't think that was a
witch hunt
but we don't have evidence that they did
the DNC servers or John Podesta Z mail
so how exactly did Russia skew the
election or interfere any more than a
dozen other countries try to interfere
every day I'm totally confused no I
think those are two separate inquiries I
don't think they impacted the results of
the election at all
Donald Trump won fair and square what
did they try to do we spent a year we
wrote a report the Senate wrote a report
I don't think there's there's not much
quarrel on the intelligence of did
Russia try to interfere so there is
there is with me I mean lots of country
I mean I've lived there my whole life
lots of countries interfere all the time
I want to know is there any evidence
that they hacked the DNC server that's
that I mean that's the central
allegation and we're hearing from the
crowd striked I know there's no evidence
so I don't know what this is about
well we couldn't answer that because
remember the the FBI did not gain access
to that server they'd even tried to gain
access to that server the DNC gave it
the CrowdStrike and we will never know
the answer to that question I think well
whether or not Russia tried to sow the
seeds of discord
I think our report did a really good job
of outlining that yes they did specific
reference to the DNC I asked that
question I don't know that anyone
connected Russia with the hacking of the
DNC or if they did I can't recall it
yeah Oh everyone did and many
Republicans did and it turns out they
didn't know that congressman thanks so
much for coming on saying good to see
you yes sir she thank you you too